and there's a future coming back into
the tournament you lost yesterday to jan
bounced back today and the first thing i
have to ask you do you know that there's
a brilliant surprise in this tournament
yes
yeah i think this is one of my very good
games i think in my career even um
i think it was very interesting this
sacrifice
and here we can show it on the board
after g5 you didn't doubt it right you
just kind of went for it how good did
you think your position was after
nineteen yeah i felt that it's winning
because of this idea of f4 and knight e2
so
um it felt when i saw okay it's
apparently long don't worry about it
actually it it the engine the more
things the more like okay okay yes
i think it's a very interesting plan and
when i saw this plan i thought it's just
winning
but he gave you a lot of trouble
actually yes i think he found a very
nice defense and it was very interesting
the way he played
it was very forcing actually i couldn't
find a better way to continue after
c-section
yes be before is correct oh it's just
yes
yes and rook f1 can use h4 is apparently
not correct wow bishop h4 liked a little
bit more but
it still thought h4 has a strong
advantage yes and then it's very forcing
actually after it takes
queen b3 is very important move
excellent move the screen yes rookie 8
and you played this absolutely great we
were just wondering
after knight takes e4
knight takes d5 yeah
what did you miss there yeah for sure
it's a good move but i thought i am
better anyway so i missed i didn't see
the wind king g6
here i was calculating rook d5 queen h4
and i couldn't see the win so yeah there
was only one win in this position
actually let's move queen f3 yeah and i
saw this one knight f6 then you can just
take takes
and this
i missed queen each
king g7
and then rook g5 yeah yeah you got the
queen okay yeah i missed queen h5 check
yeah
i i just saw queen g4 king f7 rook f5
but it doesn't
like this right looking f7 hacking f7
yeah rook f5 i think he's winning but
okay i thought the in the game i am also
better so right and he didn't have lots
of time so i thought maybe if i just
keep it and attack the king later it
would be
better practical choice because if i
miss something there i am down piece how
did you make the decision between
playing the knight to e2 and what we
thought was a more logical move knight
h5
ah yes um night i thought that i could
go back and also defend the king and
also attack the
attack his king because knight on d4 is
very powerful and knight h5 is a bit
shaky move but maybe it's a better move
so yeah well it seemed like 92 was a
little bit of a mistake according to the
engines but after 96 you were just back
in control queen d3 check here and this
excellent sequence right when did you
feel you had it in the bag yes here
because the king is so weak that it's so
easy to play with white and he didn't
have lots of time so i think i was very
optimistic here so
well absolutely you should be because
well you have a crushing position and
you ended it up with a flurry of attack
nice bounce back against levona ronyan
after three rounds how do you feel
overall about your performance yeah i
think it's very decent um john played a
fantastic game yesterday so i was not
very upset with the yesterday game
i could have defended better but i think
he just played a very amazing game so um
i think it's very decent it's 50 so i'm
happy that today managed to come back
and we will see the coming rounds we
absolutely want to see you today was a
great game congratulations on it and the
bounce back and good luck the rest of
your games thank you
congratulations to you as well
ali raza
the two remain